我今天看到一個文章，讓我突然覺得，天啊，這是不是台灣很多中小企業的救星？
怎麼說？是哪種誇大的標題嗎？「三天學會，月入百萬」那種？
不是啦，它是說「你不需要大公司的預算，也能借用它最好的系統」。這點我很意外，因為我們總覺得很多事情要有錢才能做。
嗯，這確實是很多人，包括我在內，下意識的反應。沒錢怎麼跟大公司比？人家有幾百個研發人員，幾千萬的行銷預算。
對啊，它就直接戳破這個迷思。原文的作者說，他以前看到一個大型合作夥伴做了個很棒的慈善專案，一開始也覺得「我們是小公司，怎麼可能學？」
這想法很正常。很多時候，我們看到別人厲害，第一個反應就是「我們做不到」。
但他說，他後來發現自己問錯問題了。他不是問「能不能複製這個專案」，而是問「為什麼這個專案會成功？」
為什麼？這差別在哪？
成功的關鍵是它鼓勵員工參與社區，並持續獎勵這種行為。不是專案本身有多複雜，而是背後的「系統」。
喔，所以他們不是直接抄襲那個慈善活動，而是把「鼓勵員工參與社區」這個概念，用自己公司負擔得起的方式實現？
沒錯。他們後來也開始追蹤員工的志工時數，給予獎勵。雖然形式不同，但背後讓員工投入社區的「原則」是一樣的。
這點其實蠻不容易的。很多創業者或主管，會傾向於追逐表面上那些「成功人士的習慣」，像是史蒂夫賈伯斯的黑高領毛衣，或是馬斯克的工作時程。
原文也提到了。我們常把創辦人當作偶像，研究他們的性格、習慣，甚至作息。但真正讓公司成功的，是那些「溝通系統、責任結構、文件化的流程和績效標準」。
這些東西聽起來確實不那麼「性感」，不像明星CEO的故事那麼吸引人。
但它很有用啊。原文說，2024年Deloitte的調查發現，87%的美國辦公室專業人士會把公司有沒有志工機會，當成是否留下或換工作的一個考量。這代表建立這種系統，其實也是一種投資。
等等，這裡我有疑問。大型企業很多系統，都是內部開發的複雜軟體，或是顧問花大錢設計的。中小企業真的能「借用」嗎？還是只能學個皮毛？
作者提到一個很具體的例子，就是「清晰的溝通」。他說大公司無法把所有資訊都留在老闆腦袋裡，必須對股東、董事會、員工負責，所以溝通一定要明確。
中小企業常常是老闆說了算，訊息傳達靠口頭，很容易資訊不對稱。這點我信了，因為很多團隊，光是年度目標，大家的理解可能都不同。
是啊，原文還提到一個2015年《哈佛商業評論》的研究，調查了250多家公司。結果發現，高階主管對公司未來12個月前三大優先目標的理解，差異非常大。
這點真的是痛點。如果連主管群的目標都散落一地，那底下員工更不用說了。所以「借用」大公司的溝通系統，意思是學他們怎麼確保資訊傳達一致？
對，它不是要你花錢買什麼工具。它可以是簡單到讓你的領導團隊寫下公司前三大優先目標，然後比對答案，看差距有多大。這就是一個低成本的「系統」。
這樣聽起來，好像也不需要什麼高科技。那如果是我們一般上班族，可以怎麼把這個概念帶入工作或生活？
嗯，我猜啦，我們可以想想自己部門的目標，有沒有跟主管或同事明確對齊？或者，如果我們看到某個團隊很有效率，可以去觀察他們是怎麼開會、怎麼追蹤進度的？
與其羨慕別人做得好，不如去拆解他們背後的「系統」是什麼。這樣想，好像很多事情確實可以不必花大錢，只是需要轉換一下思考方向。
是啊，當我們看到一個厲害的點子，不再只是「哇」一聲，而是去問：「它背後的運作機制是什麼？」「有哪些行為是被鼓勵、被強化的？」
然後再想想，怎麼用我們手上的資源，去建立一個小一點、適合自己的版本。
對，或許這才是真正能產生「原來可以這樣！」的啟發。
聽起來，這好像也提醒了我們，成功不只是光鮮亮麗的表面，更多的是那些不那麼起眼但卻能重複運作的系統。